[拍手]
僕のバックランドはソフトエイジやです
妄想かれこれ67年くらい
ずーっと仕事をしております
あの卒業した後に最初に入っ
ソーシャルゲーム業界の
就職しました
アメリカに赴任させて頂いたりとかまた新規事業の立ち上げとかいろいろなことをやっ
ていて
まあ今振り返ってみると結構優雅な生活をしていたかなというふうに思います
学生時代はですね位置情報の言及をしてましたただそれとは別に他にものすごい興味が
あることがありました
それっていうのはお金の仕組みです
お金の仕組み
すごい興味を持っていたので僕は
本を読んだりとかインターネットで調べてみたりとかまたあの外交政策などを折ったり
とかしてキー尾一尾興味を持って調べてみました
ここにコロッケがあります
このコロッケ結構カロリー高いので普段は僕はあんまり食べられないんですけども
記憶の中でポロッキーが一番安かった時の値段っていくらぐらいでしょうか
なんか適当に言っていただける方だ
60円
じゃああと一人ぐらいお願いします
世代がカッチャーのちょっと言いにくいかもしれないけどはい
ここにうちの父と母がいますまぁ最近丁寧代表しまして
あの旅行ばっかりしてる感じですね
母は30円
父は5円と言ってました
まあつまりコロッケに対するお金の価値っていうのは日々変動してるわけですよね
青谷の時代が30円7-時代が講演僕なんかはだいたい
80円くらいだったかなというような曲あります
そんなお金は人類最大の発明というふうに言われております
お金というのは神様を大感情とした情報感情と可能にしたものの絵風に一応学者とかは
定義をしております
そんなお金というのは
金の埋蔵量をもとに
総発行量が決められて金を2に金貨として使う
あとお店とかで者らような金本位制の時代
またそれを政府が保持して大開4辺でこの神とこの菌は同等の価値がありますと言って
交換する
以来
また
今っていうのは国の信用力を活かして
あの通貨を発行する時代と年代によって進化しております
そんな中ですね僕は2013年ビットコインというものでました
発行したいがなく
聞い中央集権型
また僕は仕事で利用しているソフトウェア
で動いている
僕はこのビットコインを勉強してみたい
このビットコインを仕事にしてみたい
そう思ったので思い切ってフリーランスになってみました
自由な働き方ができて自由に時間が使えるのはいいランスです
いざフリーランスになってみるとですねまぁ最初は大変でほぼほぼすっからかんになり
ました
なのでへ
普段使っていた居酒屋みたいのを学生時代に戻したりとか
またお金がなくなったので実家に帰ったりしました
で実際ねあの確定申告を占めると年収なんてものは半分くらいの
ただ1年くらい頑張ってみるとギリギリようやく戻ってきたかなぐらいになりました
そう思ったのでもう一回東京に暮らしてみようというふうに思い
マンションを探しでございました
社会人時代と同じような水準のマンションを応募してみたんですけども
まあ入居審査委の gto
で今度は事業で縦回避が多くなってきたのでクレジットカードを作りたいなと
思ったんですけども
実際に作ってみるとサラリーマン時代以前目に作ったクレジットカードというのは百も
150万円が減の理由
フリーランス者に作ってみるとなぜか30万円
の言動が気になっていました
自分の能力ってその時6年ぐらい働いさあです
圧倒的に診察の1年目よりも能力が伸びて
にもかかわらず社会的な信用を伸びていない
これって何なんだろうなというような思い
がものすごい強感じるようなりました
つまり今世の中の神様っていうのは
大企業に勤めているとか今資産をたくさん持っているといったことが皆さんの神様なん
です
でも今って個人の時代といわれています
なのでユーチューバーという職種が存在したりとか
インスタグラムあっっていうのは直種の触手が存在したりしていますまたあの国ももの
人づくり革命担当大臣
みたいなものを
a 棟
任命したりとしました
しているような時代ですただ僕がフリーランスに自衛権した
クレジットカードが弦高が下がったりとか不動産支えられなかったいっても
そういった社会的インフラっていうのが全くと載ってねーんだなというふうに感じ
させるような経験でした
先ほどもお伝えしましたがお金は神様交換譲渡可能にしたものです
なので僕は個人の信用を交換譲渡可能にするようなサービスそういったものを作りたい
と思って
バリューというようなサービスを論しました
バリューというものはビットコイン上にあるトークン
自分の信用を表したトークンってものを発行します
そのトークンをユーザー間でオークションのようにバイバイしてもらいます
最終価格が時価総額に現れてそれを個人の信用として数値化するっていうことがあの
サービスの内容です
たとえばここに全く売れてないようなアイドルがいたとします
バリーを通して応援してみたい
思って針を
彼女の神様あるし買ってみております
例えば彼女が物凄い
グローバル聞いたしたりとかものすごい有名になると
100万100倍の知名度みたいになりますよね
そのことによって応援して書士投資に対して100倍の資本としてリターンが得られる
ようなサービスです
ただこれをロンチてみるとですね思いっきり援助しました
ものすごい批判を受けました
企業っていうのは継続企業の前提があります富士見です
個人というのはいつか死んでしまいます必ず終わってしまいます
そのためあの個人の信用には本源的な価値がない様子に価値がない
なので詐欺だというような批判を受けました
ただ僕はバリューをそれでもやめようと思いません
その理由を今から説明したいと思います
今隣に日本銀行
皆さん見てきましたね多分表があります
日本銀行っていうのはお金の供給をコントロールしてくれています
その日本銀行がしっかりとお金の供給をコントロールしてくれることで経済ての安定し
ております
また日本銀行から提供されるお金というのは
僕らにとって彼はのような存在です
それが世の中絶対に正しく公平に嫌がって here たってことで全体が発展します
ところが
日本
銀行吐き品銀行券発行高とエイキン所得を比較してみると
それの僕たちの所得っていうのは一切増えてないことがわかります
その代わり日本銀行が供給する
日本のお金の量とな増え続けてい
またこういったことをフランスの経済学者のピケティさんは r ダイナリジー
という数式がだしています
今っていうの中はお金でお金を生み出した方が
お金持ちになるよどんなに頑張ったとしても
2の商売をしていてばお金持ちになるにそのためどんどん格差が広がっている
つまり今の
お金の流れというのは
ある一部の曲射的なところに流れていてそこだけは経済発展しているそんな状態です
なので僕はバリューというものをつくって
ここにお金を流せるような仕組みを作りたいというふうに思ってい
今というのは僕みたいな起業家が信用を資本化するって言うためには
m & a で会社を売却したりとか
上場という形ことをしなければなりません
その金融マーケットには種類株仗助
またよくわかんないデリバティブ商品
そういったものを
どんどんどんどん進化していって
今までは常に資本化された信用を進化させてきた
っていうのが今までの経済発展です
このことで拡散広がっています
僕はそれを
神様を資本化できる3位ラインというものを
バリーを用いてものすごく下げています
これまでの4本というのはあ
仗助
しないできなかったんですけどもバリューっていうのを使ってくれば新しい資本的な
価値っていうのを得られるようになります
その
どういった今後個人以外にどういった神様が交換譲渡可能になるかと考えてみると今か
全く価値のない npo 法人
いやー
過疎化されている地方のコミュニティ
っていうものがどんどんどんどん
交換チェーン方向3型の神様が交換譲渡可能になってくるんじゃないかなというふうに
僕は想像しています
そのことで今まで
思いっきり格差があった経済というものがもう少しよくなるんじゃないかなというふう
に思っています
神様を資本化できる種類を増やすことで社会全体にお金
つまり神様多いきがたらすることができるそれがバリューをやってる
トークンへ好みというブロックチェーンを利用して新しく試みていることです
トークンエコノ宮バリューっていうのはまだまだ始まったばっかりです
ビッド今やブロックチェーンも今大きな問題が起こっています
ただ僕が言いたいのはそういった問題を一個一個潰すことで
世の中全体にいいこと格差がない社会
新しい神様が好感情される世界っていうのが来るんじゃないかなというふうに思ってい
ます
どんな仕様を交換可能し資本化するといいのか一緒に考えて
より良い社会を作りましょう
こういったことが僕は
新しい21世紀型の資本主義になると思っています
ありがとうございました
[拍手]